they know it we know it they just
can't admit
it that's why you have in the house this
Skirmish between margorie Taylor green
and Chip Roy well and others but have
you seen this holy
she even she even went after Lauren
bobbert oh this is great you know I
think we pick out really good
nicknames here here on the Tony Michaels
podcast one of them for Marjorie Taylor
green came from the chat the petty Yeti
um it is the inspiration for the yeti of
the house if you if you want to know the
truth this is where the petty Yeti comes
from here here She is uh in the House of
Representatives here here's a picture of
Marjorie Taylor Green live the petty
Yeti the the house Squatch there um but
again this morning or yesterday actually
I should say but this morning there's a
little bit more you know to this story
because margorie Taylor green now came
up in the press conference with the new
wiener of the house and he was asked
about this little Skirmish here but chip
Roy press office I love this I love how
how these these Republicans and any
politician really if you want to say it
I'm good with that because they have
official representative accounts you see
this is is rep chip Roy this is his
official account as a congress person
that's what the gray check mark is about
on TW on on xchan here I think that's
what I'm going to start calling it xchan
is great it's Twitter or it's xchan one
or the other um but chip Roy's
official Congressional account here it's
not representative chip Roy you see it's
press office that way if something gets
tweeted out in this thing wrong he can
just blame it on his staff he doesn't
have to blame it on himself he doesn't
have to be held accountable they don't
want to be held accountable for anything
anyways but here's chip Roy talking
about the the centure um motion that
marjor Taylor green brought to the floor
and it was
tabled H they can't it's so funny it's
so funny Republicans can't govern like
literally they can't expel one of their
criminal uh colleagues George
Santos and they can't they can't centure
representative Talib for her pro pro
Palestinian which appears in some
instance to be pramas I'm not going to
lie TB has gone way over the line with
some of this stuff now rather she should
be censored in Congress you know that's
up for Congress to decide the problem is
they decided that she shouldn't and the
reason why is because Marjorie Taylor
Green in her language of the of the
motion called her an insurrectionist and
they were like sh xay on the
Insurrection a like what are you doing
why are you saying this Insurrection Stu
out loud even chip Roy understands that
you can't can't say this type of in
the way that margerie Taylor green
saying it I showed you a video during
the pro Palestinian protest I believe it
was last week where Margie Taylor green
is standing out on the
capital on on the on the steps and she's
saying this is an inter this is an ins
and it's a protest not an Insurrection
they weren't trying to stop official
proceeding to overturn the government
they were just protesting to the
government but you
know boneheads um but here here
here is um here's here's chip Roy's
tweet says representa Lee has repeatedly
made outrageous remarks towards Israel
and Jewish people her conduct is
Unbecoming of a member of Congress and
certainly worthy of condemnation if not
censur um he goes on however tonight's
feckless resolution to censure TB was
deeply flawed see he's not opposed to
getting rid of her he's not opposed to
silencing her freedom of speech
right this is from the freedom of speech
people I don't actually think she should
be censored I think some of the stuff
she's saying is not not good for her to
say but I don't actually think that it
matters uh to her seat of Congress if
you want to know the honest
truth that's that's the thing again I
don't agree with some of the she's
saying I don't agree with some of that
but that's not again she's not
gonna agree with I say you see what
I mean you see what I mean like you know
Liberty and and I actually do not I
I actually do not think that that that
it affects her congressional seat in in
that way I really don't um because
they're trying to paint her up as some
sort of terrorist terrorist sympathizer
and I don't think that's actually what
she's doing um but you know talib's
gonna do what she thinks is best and if
she can't get her reelected because she
says that well that's just how the
cookie crumbles uh but Chi Roy goes on
he says I voted to table the
resolution
oh these scum eggs in January 20
here we go listen to this because
margorie Taylor green TR made this a
January 6th issue right now she just
didn't want to censure what Talib had
said out loud she wanted to censor her
because she had participated with the
protesters at which again I I believe
that member members of Congress should
be able to protest as members of
Congress and I think they should be able
to Pro peacefully protest t as members
of Congress who aren't acting as
official members of Congress they're
acting as American citizens so you know
and there's a gray area there right and
that's what you have to determine on
motions on the floor of the house but
chip Roy is really pissed off that
margorie Taylor green invoked the
January 6th insurrectionist and the
reason why is because when margorie
Taylor green calls a pro Palestinian
protest a peaceful Pro Palestinian
protest that doesn't result in violence
or I don't know trying to overthrow our
Constitution bonehead when you
point out that that's an Insurrection
right when you say that's an
Insurrection and you're passing a motion
on the floor and they're voting for a
motion on the floor to call it an
Insurrection
because January 6 was an Insurrection
you're admitting margerie margorie M
Marge Marge listen listen really clear
if you're going to
say that the pro Palestinian protests
are an Insurrection like the January 6
Insurrection is Insurrection you're
admitting that January 6 was an
Insurrection how the don't they
know this I mean chip Roy knows it
he says I voted to table the resolution
in January 2021 the legal term
Insurrection was stretched and abused
because he is an insurrectionist I don't
know if you know that chip Roy is an
insurrectionist by many following the
events at the capital we should not
continue to perpetrate claims of
insurrections at the capital and we
should not abuse the term now uh and
this is a quote by Roy because this is
from his press office account funny part
is is M the petty Yeti the house Squatch
she
responded uh and that's what the Uproar
is about that's why the the wiener of
the house was asked about this this
morning and his press conference but
margorie Taylor green said said here you
voted to kick me out of the freedom
caucus oh boy I tell you what there's a
lot there's a lot going on here she's
really pissed off at chip Roy and Chip
Roy hates this
idiot even as even as much of a scumbag
and a dumb that chip Roy is he even
knows that this piece of margorie
Taylor green is not good for their party
even he knows it wow that's wild stuff I
mean he voted to kick her out of the
freedom caucus you remember that because
I think this was the whole um her and
Lauren bobert she called Lauren bobert a
little but listen to
this it gets good but keep but keep
seeing in wannabe Ken Buck who who is no
longer gonna run for his seat in
Congress because of like this right
Ken Buck's like you I'm out you
people are crazy I'm not I'm not
going to do the crazy
anymore but the next part oh is so
delicious and vaping groping
Lauren bobbert this is real this
is not AI I did not make this image up
this is not a produced image this is a
real tweet this is
real real or is
it nope it's real 100% I wish I could
say that it's fake I wish I could say
that because at first I had to go verify
this I was like surely this isn't real
because I seen it as a screenshot I'm
like I gotta go see this
nope it's real it's right there she
wrote this on her official account
on her rep account this isn't her
personal account this is her official
Congressional account and she calls
herself a Christian on it Christian
mother American business owner and
congresswoman representing georg's 14th
District 2.8 million bot
followers is what she's got
but she's a Christian and she calls
Lauren bobert a vaping grouping Lauren
bobert I'm all here for it folks I'm not
goingon to take the shovel out of their
hand she also goes on to tell Chip Roy
and she says a lot of ANS in this thing
I'm not gonna lie and you voted with the
Democrats to protect terus Talib you
hate
Trump certified Biden's election and
could care less about January 6
defendants being prosecuted persecuted
she clearly does not understand what
he's trying to tell her he's like hey
dummy when you call the pro peaceful
protest and Insurrection because you
don't like that they call the January 6
Insurrection Insurrection you're
admitting that the January 6
Insurrection is an Insurrection it's
real weird
stuff totally weird but you know that's
how it goes and this morning
um well let me wait a second I got to
respond to this tweet because this is a
beautiful tweet but it sucks so this
tweet sucks this is what I do I want to
show you guys this so like when she
tweets this and I show it on the show I
go down and I I tell her it sucks and
then I tell her it's featured on the
show and I do it when it's a good tweet
too like when someone's showing a clip
and I play the clip I give them credit
for it I try to give people credit I
just want to show you guys I don't know
if you guys some of you guys know that
because some of you guys go like those
comments on Twitter but I want to show
you that um here's here's what I said to
this this tweet and then I'll show you
what the the wiener of the house said I
said don't put down the shovel please
Marge don't put down the shovel please
please please don't put down the
[Music]
shovel